Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie huge news we actually
have some season seven footage.
So there's like a really short HBO trailer
I'm going to loop a couple times because it's
so short and its super janky so hopefully
they'll post a high-res version real soon,
but here it is
so we have Jon Sansa and Aryaa, and it looks
like Jon and Sansa are at winter fell here
of some better pictures of this there little
bit better resolution.
So you almost wouldn't know that this is footage
from season seven if they didn't tell you
in that HBO trailer so they kinda did this
last year than they started releasing bran
teasers and stuff, so I would expect little
things like this to start dropping through
the rest of the year even though game of thrones
is a can of premier till the middle of next
year like weight later than April like late
June early July will still be dropping stuff
like this don't want to get people hyped up
so though still be game of thrones season
seven things happening throughout the year
but we excellent some cool stuff from this
so if you look at Jon he's weAryang the same
outfit.
He was at the end of season six it's almost
dead on the same outfit that Robb Stark was
weAryang before he died.
So like all the star children are starting
to look and dress like their parents like
Robb started to look like Ned Stark a little
bit this Sansa image is even more telling.
She's weAryang a Catlin Stark wig.
So if you're wondering why she's weAryang
the wig is because she died her hair blonde
in real life, for whatever reason, for whatever
other project she's working on, but Sansa
needs to have red hair now is just looking
more and more like Catlin's hair so she slowly
becoming her mother, but Arya is a little
harder to partially she's on a horse.
So it's hard to tell where she is, she was
last at the twins down here.
So it looks like she's headed north.
Maybe she makes her way up to winter fell
this is kind of like a Stark teaser trailer.
So it would seem to imply pure because Jon
and Sansa are at winter fell in this that
Aryaa would make her way up there eventually
but the thing is is that they're all so different
from where they were the last time they were
altogether way back in season one that's how
long it's been like George RR Martin said
that when the story starts out everyone starts
in the same place that is the story gets on
it slowly pulls them all in different directions
and as you reach the end of the story.
They all start to converge again so now the
were hitting wins a winter in the books were
hitting the last couple of seasons.
Everyone is started to converge again.
Even though there are a bunch of characters
on game of thrones they largely framed that
first season at Starks versus Lannister.
So it seems like we might be going back to
that.
Just a little bit, but the thing is is that
they been gone for so long they change so
much.
I wouldn't assume they're all going to be
super best friends when they get back together,
there's already problems between Sansa and
Jon right now the character that it looks
like he's talking to on the battlements a
winter fell here looks like Sansa so this
is all probably from that first episode they
been shooting for a while but there still
like a couple of the big action set pieces
that there filming right now we don't really
to talk about them.
I know people are really big on spoilers and
is still really really early so we can talk
about that stuff later on it just that you
always expect them to echo the big tent poles
of each season like battle of the Bastard's
in each successive season so like we had Blackwater
than the red wedding then watchers on the
wall in the battle of the Bastard's there
will be something like that in the final season
and part of the reason why they had to reduce
the episode count to seven episodes is because
a lot more of them will be films like the
battle of the Bastard's episode whole bunch
of people lots of extras lots of animals like
everything cranked up to 11 Soviet is a bummer
the ring I could get those extra three episodes
but each of the episodes they are filming
are supposed to make up for that.
So they haven't said anything about how long
the episodes are actually going to be but
well past 60 minutes.
So will be interesting to see if they can
clean up what's happening in and around winter
fell in the North after the battle of the
Bastards what Sansa will want to do about
her mother's home Riverrun because it is almost
like the new Heron Hall of the river land
which is kind of funny because haired Hall
is in the river lands but just look at the
map here see how close they are to the Eyrie
littlefinger has all those troops so he might
be able to tempt Sansa with freeing Riverrun
from Lannister control then you have the brotherhood
that slowly making its way north to they were
last seen near the salt pans when the hound
join their band.
They told him they were heading north.
So it seems like a lot of these characters
are all heading North so far.
It has a horse it seems like that reunion
will take place at winter fell, which doesn't
say anything about bran he is nowhere in this
teaser which may be just because they want
to keep it really short, but Ellie Kendrick
was talking about how she still has to haul
him around so the moving way slower, so is
gonna take them way longer to get to winter
fell if that's where they're going that they
still need to go to the wall.
First, you guys can let me know.
Do you think that all the star children will
converge the same time or if like or will
make her way to winter fell they'll all freak
out even though Sansa knows that she still
alive Brienne told her that she saw her before
she went east and then do you think that bran
will come in and explain everything all the
visions that he's had the past that he seen
the truth of Jon snows parentage the way the
show disseminates information like that like
the information that bran has usually gets
attached to other really big moments like
you see Jon Snow named King of the North.
Just as you find out who his mother truly
is implied who his father is.
Even though unofficially behind-the-scenes
HBO confirmed that radar Targaryen is his
father.
You can only wonder what's also going to say
about this when she finds out, and whether
or not little finger already knows or suspects
it I don't think that he does because if he
didn't know what Ramsey was doing to Sansa
during season five that it doesn't seem like
he would know one of the best kept secrets
in the history of a song of ice and fire.
But Arya has always loved Jon even if she's
a completely different person inside.
I feel like they'll have some common bond
like it will be pretty easy for them to pick
up where they left off.
She wasn't too hot on Sansa, but she does
love her sister.
So even if there's some friction I'm just
expecting them to fight a lot in the way that
sisters would do just that Arya is a lot more
Stalvey that she used to be.
If you remember Jon is the one that gave her
needle.
So the be fun to see her rollup twice as big
with needle on her hip bran arriving and telling
him there's so many bigger things that need
to worry about is probably was going to keep
them from jumping at each other's throats
you guys can let me know what you feel like
the drama is going to be between the stark
children and while you guys think about that
I'm going to be doing some epic fight night
videos like Arya versus the mountain.
Just epic battles in game of thrones, even
if they haven't happened in the books.
So be sure to subscribe to get that and there
is a new round of the giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Make sure if you are subscribed that you turn
alerts on just because YouTube has been messing
around with the placement of everything so
lots more game of thrones coming and then
there's also some Rick and Morty that I'll
be posting this week too If you haven't seen
it you will definitely be down for it be on
the lookout for some Rick and Morty dropping
on my channel this week, in addition to more
game of thrones while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for my top 10 crazy
theories and you can click here for my Westworld
episode nine episode 10 trailer video think
you so much watching everybody high five I'll
see you guys tonight!